this is evidently not the chemistry
department and the count of the
chemistry department not having eleven
sofa I'm currently at home having been
signed off work for three weeks because
of a ruptured Achilles tendon so in
other words the Achilles which is this
very large ligament the back I'll
indicate with my good leg along here
went pop and it was a freak accident at
chemistry I wasn't doing anything
dangerous I wasn't running around I
wasn't leaping down several flights of
stairs I simply walked across the foyer
of chemistry and all of a sudden I heard
the snap I was really sad about Sam's
injury nothing to do with chemistry but
it's always sad when a friend hurts
themselves technically it was it
happened in chemistry but I wish it was
a more exciting story that I could tell
to people other than I was just walking
and it just happened but it is a good
opportunity for our plaster video which
we might not have made otherwise and
many of you may be sitting watching with
your limbs in plaster and you don't
realize you've got quite a nice piece of
chemistry there
so this isn't the first cast I've had on
so three weeks ago were there about when
it actually happened I went to the
hospital they did the diagnosis first of
all where they made me kneel up against
onto a chair so I was facing the wall my
legs were back there and then the nurse
proceeded to just prod and poke the back
of my leg and till of screaming with
pain and then she said oh yeah you've
definitely snapped your Achilles I'll
Thanks
plaster or so-called plaster of Paris is
made from the mineral gypsum which is
calcium sulfate to make plaster of Paris
you take gypsum which is calcium sulfate
which has water molecules within the
crystal structure between the calcium
and sulphate ions and you heat it up
hard and drive off most of the water and
then you take this powdered material mix
it with water and the water gets
absorbed back into the crystals with
quite a lot of evolution of heat so then
she said right we'll take you straight
to the plaster room so I was intrigued I
thought surely they'd have to do it you
know not an x-ray because that's for
bones but I thought maybe ultrasound or
something but no they just she just felt
where it basically come apart and then
they took me round to the plaster room
and that's when I was put into the kind
of traditional cast so this is the
plaster of Paris heavy clunky dirty
messy procedure there have been cases of
people who've tried to make a plaster
cast of their whole body being seriously
injured because they got burnt from the
heat of this reaction just adding water
to plaster of Paris so you have to be
pretty careful and it's rather like
cement but it's not nearly as strong
because after all once the person's
injury is healed you want to get the
plaster off without having to break
their leg at the same time
and then once you've got the plaster on
she let it set for I think it was about
15 minutes 20 minutes something like
that and then off I went and so what was
different between the plaster Paris cast
and this one was that there was a big
gap along here and the reason why is
because over that weekend there was
every chance that my leg would swell up
as a result of healing and coping with
the damage done calcium sulfate plaster
of Paris is not very strong that's why
if you have plaster of Paris models in
museums and somebody attacks it with a
hammer or something it smashes into lots
of little pieces but it's strong enough
to hold your arm or leg rigid but it's
quite heavy so nowadays they use glass
fiber reinforcement so this cost you can
see there's no gap it's several strips
of the fiberglass that's been wrapped
around the leg so you start off with the
cotton wool wrapped around this this
kind of sleeve that folds over it's over
the cotton wall the fiberglass and
polyurethane now fiberglass is pretty
much where says on the tin very fine
fibers of glass now normally you'd think
you glass panes you know windows that
sort of thing it's a rigid hard strong
structure so by turning it into these
very thin fibers it becomes moldable and
flexible but it still retains the
strength of the glass so what you've got
there obviously you can't just get
bunches of glass fire and just just wrap
it round you need something that's going
to make it extra moldable and also
sticky as well something that's going to
bind everything together and that's
where the polyurethane comes in so
polyurethane is a type of polymer ie a
plastic what I call glass from Paris I
think because it originally came from
Paris I believe the famous hill of moher
March the one that the artists all got
drunk on has quite large deposits of
gypsum underneath it and that's where
it's happened to be mined or porridge
for the first time when
people start making plaster so this is
actually yeah this is the first time
I've had my foot in plaster and I
remember back when we were kids my
brother and I my brother was a very
boisterous young man and he always had a
broken arm
he broke is on four times during his
childhood and every single time it was
this really heavy thick tough and rough
rough surface of plaster of Paris and
you'd see this and it just looked like
it was like a brick and the thing is
with this kind of plaster it's just for
a start you can see the definition of
the heel there and round here it's
obviously a lot more flexible moldable
than plaster of Paris it's also
considerably lighter as well that's the
thing with plasters the tradition is
that you as soon as as people are able
to they'll start putting graffiti and
all sorts on here I think that the this
is where I think the only benefit of
having plaster Paris is is that it's
slightly easier to write on although
you've got the rough bits you've also
got smoother bits as well whereas are
the fiberglass you can see there the
grooves that's why it's not as easy to
write them but all this writing has been
done by my sister